messieurs dames bonjour bonjour le
concept d'aujourd'hui je l'aime
particulièrement vous savez on est tous
fans ici des sosies ça nous fait mourir
de rire j'ai déjà fait une vidéo à ce
sujet il y a pas mal de temps c'est lui
il a carrément un compte insta presque 7
sur lequel il pose des photos de ses
sosies on est très fan de ça aujourd'hui
on a trouvé une idée de concept qui peut
potentiellement complètement foirer mais
qui n'en sera pas pour le moins amusant
l'audace nous allons faire venir six
abonnés à tour de rôle chacun pense
qu'il vient pour faire une activité
manuelle avec nous à savoir de la
poterie ce qui est sympa déjà comme une
vidéo de base sympa de faire de la
poterie avec les abonnés
nous avons un objectif secret
aujourd'hui il y a trois sosies un
sosies de scène un sosie de Lorraine un
sosie de moi j'ai une question comment
vous avez fait le casting
développée par la Squeezie industries
très fort nous allons devoir pendant
cette fausse vidéo activité manuelle
nous remplacer chacun notre tour par
notre sosie c'est-à-dire on va devoir
chacun de Tours se lever sortir de la
pièce et faire rentrer notre sosie à
notre place evidemment l'abonner il va
s'en rendre compte au bout d'un moment
donc le vrai but c'est pas qu'il s'en
rend pas compte c'est qu'il n'ose pas le
dire à haute voix sachant que quand vous
envoyez votre sosie vous allez en
cuisine et tu vois et tu as un retour
vidéo de ce qui se passe ici donc tu
peux voir un peu comment ça se passe
pour les collègues moi je veux
qu'aujourd'hui sur ces six personnes
nues d'entre elles se retrouvent assise
ici avec nos trois sosies sans avoir osé
dire quoi que ce soit attendez je vous
préviens c'est crin genre ça va vous
glacer bien mais qu'est-ce qu'on aime
pas
il est donc maintenant temps de
rencontrer nos sosie qui pour le moment
sont pas des sosies sont plus des gens
qui nous ressemblent plus ou moins et
qu'on va devoir du coup habiller comme
nous grimer comme nous quoi fait comme
nous pour qu'on se ressemble le plus
plus possible chacun rejoint son sosie
et on se retrouve après on découvre les
autres allez c'est parti
comment ça s'appelle bah c'est Lucas et
toi c'est Lucas aussi incroyable Lucas
le casting est complètement réussi tu es
Lucille luciole on est pas loin ma
grand-mère m'appelle Lucie à l'épée
j'ai jamais rencontré quelqu'un qui me
ressemble c'est la première fois et donc
juste pour ça je suis très heureux que
ce soit honoré Kendall premier sosie Bam
Bam Bam en gros nous c'est le plus
risqué les abonnés qui vont venir c'est
regarde mes vidéos ils m'ont scanner ils
m'ont vu mille fois à l'écran donc ils
savent parfaitement à quoi je ressemble
nous on a un peu cet avantage là ceux
qui vont plus être sur Lucas sur Seb ils
ont plus l'habitude de les voir etc
bisous de me voir mais pas tant que ça
je fais des vidéos sur la musique si
jamais ils sont là ils disent ouais
lourdes et son nanana tu dis il y a du
lourd qui arrive c'est quand même de ouf
ce qui se passe on va atteindre la
perfection voyons voir nos fringues on a
les mêmes chaussures on a les mêmes
chaussettes t-shirt super jogging si tu
renverses un truc là dessus on est mort
il stagne tout tatouage franchement
c'est pas mal c'est génial c'est un
pitié par contre que ça marche bien
c'est la teinte de quand je l'ai fait
impeccable
nous allons désormais découvrir les
sosies quasi parfait
je vous donne juste une astuce
moi il est aussi
et l'équation parfaite quand il arrive
vous allez voir est-ce qu'on peut faire
entrer
[Musique]
c'est pas ouf regardez c'est quand même
bouleversant
nous on a un pronostic c'est qu'on ne se
fait pas griller une seule fois
regardez bien la bravo les filles pour
être ensemble
ok comment il s'appelle Gwendal vas-y
vas-y je te laisse avec Gwendal
bienvenue
moi sachez que mon sosie est le même
prénom que moi il s'appelle Lucas on
accueille Lucas du coup
c'est quoi j'ai envie de laisser les
deux faire une vidéo
enchanté tout le monde
regardons nos détails
vous deux c'est abuser je vous dis un
truc là je suis en full stress vraiment
je gère très mal les situations cringe
là et là on va vivre du crime mon pote
du jus de crise le but c'est que enfin
switch complet est-ce que vous êtes
prêts non
clairement non mais allons-y allez go
let's go c'est parti c'est parti
hello comment tu vas bien
désolé pour l'attente là tu as vu il y a
plein de caméra c'était long d'installer
tout en plus c'est la première à passer
je stresse là la pression
la première personne avec qui on va
faire de la sculpture désolé ça commence
un peu direct
je rappelle Asma 20 minutes pour faire
l'objet sur lequel on va tomber
[Applaudissements]
le but c'est d'avoir la plus belle
banane à la dans 19 minutes et 19
secondes ça va franchement 20 minutes
pour une banane
attends moi j'ai un problème parce qu'il
faut que j'aille faire pipi [ __ ]
est-ce que
vas-y vas-y vas-y Lorraine va aux
toilette après voilà c'est pour est-ce
que je me dis bon j'ai un peu le temps
vas-y j'arrive moi mon truc
[Musique]
en fait c'est chaud d'avoir une forme
nickel toi ça va tu t'en sors bien
encore mais je me vois l'image j'ai
l'impression d'être dans Matrix ou un
truc comme ça du retard il faut que tu
bombes il faut vraiment let's go let's
go
c'est dommage
[Rires]
[Musique]
le silence mais regarde comment on est
mort on dirait qu'on est on dirait pas
on fait la gueule en plus tu t'en sors
de fou là c'est un truc de fou sans
déconner ou quoi
non comment c'est possible pour partir
j'en ai partout là je peux me laver les
mains Valentine j'en ai partout
[Musique]
tu es content là
Asma en taperqué parce que le vrai but
de la vidéo c'est pas la banane
note les bananes il a tout donné
nous c'est pas mal non non non
est-ce qu'on peut applaudir un smile une
dernière fois qu'elle était incroyable
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais on a atteint l'objectif la dès la
première guerre
énormément parler et le souci c'est que
les gars briefez
on passe au level 2 les sosies peuvent
parler
nous recevons avec nous Bilal
c'est le moment de faire tes preuves
écoute on va avoir un modèle qui va nous
a donné nous avons 10 minutes ok
un escargot c'est trop mignon un
escargot en plus c'est pas si mignon je
crois je crois que tu te trompes
tout va bien tranquille ok
Lorraine donne-nous des conseils genre
c'est toi la bosse en fait je suis
concentrées
cinq minutes attends je vais me sécher
les mains parce que j'ai trop de trucs
je vais me sécher les mains je vais
faire la technique de Bilal direct
[Musique]
[Rires]
j'y vais du coup
[Musique]
[Rires]
ok cool
là franchement on est serré il y a pas
il y a pas quelqu'un qui se démarque des
autres
ou est-ce que George rentre chez moi et
je laisse le café dans la journée ici je
suis foutu partout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est sorti et le sosie de Seb le
second
salut il a gagné
et une nouvelle fois c'est la bonnet qui
gagne de très très loin avec cette
sculpture Bilal mon frère tu m'as régalé
c'était trop drôle les amis déjà
pourquoi ça se passe aussi bien c'est
trop suspect en fait on a sous-estimé à
quel point c'est impressionnant de
devoir dire c'était pas toi là il y a
deux minutes c'est hyper dur je ne veux
plus rester ici jusqu'à la fin je n'en
peux plus laissez-moi qui reste ici
jusqu'à la fin ok moi ce que je propose
déjà c'est qu'on switch l'idéal serait
que c'est moi qui parte en premier la
personne la plus proche voilà je vais me
faire très discret moi je vais me plaire
le truc c'est que lui on peut pas lui
demander de beaucoup parler moi je vais
le lancer alors
[Rires]
comment tu vas incroyable attends je
suis en train de dormir là c'est quoi
ton prénom
Ellison Ellison bienvenue
jamais rien tu as fait quoi tu as déjà
fait le truc manuel genre dessin
nous sommes prêts tous prêts
une couronne une couronne
et on fait un trou dedans
non mais en vrai ce qui est dur c'est la
poterie
en fait je vais te surveillante je vais
passer un concours 3 ans après pour
devenir prof d'art plastique et si je
peux faire à côté essayer de faire des
streams aussi et en ce moment je joue
beaucoup à raccompagner
twitch sur compagnie toi
je le sens ah merci
tu devais te mettre une note sur 10 en
activité manuelle tu te donnerais
combien pour l'instant - 1 - 1 ça passe
c'est pas moi
ah tu veux que j'aille le ok ok
ça parle là je suis plutôt fière de ce
que je fais
[Rires]
dans l'absurde conceptuel
tu parles tu dis n'importe quoi
il reste 3 minutes
j'étais en train de faire l'oeuvre de ma
vie
[Musique]
quand j'étais au collège j'avais un prof
d'art plastique qui notait à la tête
ils font que de parler
de la chance bah oui parce que on va
dire que
on est beaucoup mieux que la nôtre 2030
[Musique]
avec toutes les activités manuelles
qu'on a faites le compteur
[Musique]
je me suis dit que c'était normal
j'avais un truc urgent à faire du coup
je vous laisse
c'est bizarre mais vraiment je savais
pas que tu étais juste installer c'est
fou que sur trois personnes il y en ait
aucune qui dit un truc il va falloir
faire une dingue on va devoir augmenter
le niveau messieurs dames on en a marre
là que ça se passe trop bien là on va on
va y aller au kilo de fou première étape
Lorraine a une brillante idée Lucile est
caché dès le début sous la table et moi
ce que je vais faire c'est que je vais
prendre un outil de Lolo et je vais
l'envoyer sous la table et en envoyant
sous la table du coup je vais dire ah ah
va chercher horrible blague mais le swap
entre vous deux il va être chaud parce
que il va falloir que si elle sort par
là-bas pendant que toi tu rentres et
nous on va leur faire beaucoup de
beaucoup de bruit ah tu vois de toute
façon moi aussi je vais crier ces gens
là tu es trop chiant et tout machin tu
vois on fait grave du bruit là nous
sommes au level 4 du coup level 4
[Applaudissements]
là
frérotte tu vas découvrir tu arrives
dans l'atelier ici comment tu t'appelles
Willis
[Rires]
je lance ce chrono 10 minutes dès que
Valentine nous a montré l'objet à copier
attention il s'agit des lunettes
des lunettes ok let's go il faut faire
des branches prenez le couteau pour se
couper votre truc
Lolo elle va avoir besoin de se couteau
ok Lolo elle est très fort par rapport à
nous elle est super fort
tu vas bien tu le trouves ton couteau tu
me trouves allez bonne chance
ok Willis je peux faire tout en même
temps c'est à dire que moi je peux faire
de la poterie je peux voir que les gens
changent
comme ça
est-ce qu'on peut applaudir quand même
Willy
on a eu le temps de changer
que s'est passé à chaque fois
revenez
la première personne
c'est incroyable que ça a duré moins de
2 minutes est-ce qu'on peut accueillir
quand même les autres sosies
il est pas
compactisme ce qui vient de se passer tu
sais je ne croyais en principe on était
les Avengers bon c'est un peu frustrant
mais reste deux personnes là je pense
que sur les trucs audacieux on prend le
temps parce que là on l'a fait au bout
d'une minute au cas où on tombe sur un
Willis
on a eu un excès de confiance au bout de
3 minutes on commence un peu à aller on
y va et on envoie la sauce on envoie le
prochain allez les amis allez c'est
parti
hello hello c'est quoi ton prénom pardon
bienvenue Jeanne on est en train de
faire de s'entraîner pour notre atelier
vraiment rassure-toi on n'est pas sur un
niveau vraiment 100% des fois est-ce que
tu as déjà fait de la batterie je
regardais les vidéos donc de Squeezie
avant et je me suis dit bon Patrice a
déjà été fait ils vont pas
dans cette pièce ouais ouais on a des
couteaux dans la cuisine
et oui
je vais rêver de poterie là
c'est pas mon truc ah trop bien merci
toi tu fais du des heures sup' quoi
Lorraine s'il te plaît est-ce que tu
peux me refaire
rapidement rapidement j'étais en train
de faire une demande
on dirait vraiment juste un arbre en
fait un mois concrètement
ton cactus
30 non mais déjà incroyable
elle a plein de plantes chez elle elle
connaît tout [ __ ] tu te souviens
l'aloe vera qu'on avait au bureau elle
est dead
le coup de pression est lancé il faut
que je me sèche les mains
c'est trop
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
fort de ouf tu as pas vu
j'étais là
je me suis dit
c'est fou ce qui s'est passé c'est
incroyable jusqu'à moi elle a pas vu
quoi non mais c'est fou alors qu'on
avait commencé la journée en disant oui
l'objectif ultime c'est ça on a fait que
faire l'objectif donc pour cette fois on
s'est dit on va pas refaire comme d'hab
autour partout cette fois au bout de 3
minutes la bonnet va être appelé parce
qu'il a un problème technique comme nous
quand on sort et quand il va revenir ce
sera directement nos trois souris en
place ça si ça passe c'est genre ok tu
peux faire venir la dernière personne
c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
on fait de la poterie depuis ce matin
donc nous sommes professionnels
tu peux nous montrer le dernier objet de
cette journée
let's go c'est le boss final en fait je
sais même pas je sais même pas par où
commencer en fait
le micro
pose pause ah tu dois échanger son micro
en bas en bas en bas en bas en bas tu
vas pouvoir
de la cuisine avec tous les soucis
les gars c'est mon possible ça pas ça
ok c'est bon tout est réglé
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est quoi ton cheminement de pensée là
j'ai regardé je me suis dit pas beaucoup
tu vois puis après j'ai vu Lucas je me
suis dit
le vrai but c'était vraiment de sois pas
avec des sosies sauf que comme tu es le
dernier on s'est dit comme tel dernier
on s'est dit
on se soif tous ensemble
100% j'aurais rien capté
est-ce que tu te rends compte de tout ça
là pour la valeur de temps que tu as
vécu faire tes vidéos pour moi je vais
être là pendant 10 secondes
max du coup ça c'était juste un prétexte
mais au final on décide quand même de
définir un gagnant max je suis désolé tu
n'as pas gagné
c'est pas grave on peut pas griller des
sosies en une seconde et gagner
généralement c'est l'un ou l'autre moi
je pense que c'est Lauren qui correspond
au thème mais celui de Sam il est
incroyable mais il est couché quoi
pourquoi est-ce que ça
[Applaudissements]
c'est la fin de cette vidéo j'ai passé
un moment merveilleux je vous dis la
vérité je suis choqué de fou que ça ait
autant marcher c'est trop drôle
tester les limites après c'est normal
c'est ce mélange de impressionner par le
tournage impressionné aussi peut-être de
nous voir en vrai tu vois je pense qu'il
est la plupart regardez énormément de
vidéos depuis un bon moment mais en vrai
de vrai il y a quand même un truc c'est
que des fois il voyait vraiment pas
celles soit pour toi soit des fois il
voyait vraiment pas quoi moi j'aimerais
bien le vivre de l'autre côté là voir ce
que ça fait qu'est-ce qui disjonctes
exactement en tout cas merci évidemment
à Lucas Gwendal et Lucile nos sosie ils
ont été très bons en vrai de vrai c'est
pas facile ce qu'on leur a demandé ils
font pas de la vidéo ils font pas tout
ça c'est un exercice qui est quand même
compliqué c'est impressionnant merci
encore vous avez régalé c'est la fin de
cette vidéo c'est la fin c'est 8h de
tournage je suis heureux d'avoir vécu ça
avec vous c'était genre ouf je
regarderai un souvenir de fou bref
faites un petit bisou à mes squeezos là
rassurez-vous désolé
[Musique]